mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
eric verhaeghe fondateur du courrier des
stratèges bonjour et merci des choses en
direct avec nous sur rt france le vote
cet après-midi tout de suite après les
débats est ce que c'est trop rapide
pourquoi ce sentiment de précipitations
que ressentent certains députés selon
vous
d'abord parce que le temps laissé
effectivement aux gros pour constituer
ou définir une ligne politique sur la
question du dit confirmant est
extrêmement court et on peut penser
surtout dans des débats virtuel ou des
débats numérique que ça va réduire la
capacité de l'opposition à mener une
véritable délibération démocratique mais
ce qui pose problème c'est que la france
est le pays d'europe qui prévoit de
descons fine et le plus tard tous les
autres pays d'europe où 11 mai au ronde
des confiné peu ou prou avec différentes
limitations mais tous les pays auront
des confiné sera le cas de l'allemagne
de la grande bretagne de l'italie de
l'espagne
tous ces pays là ont donné l'exemple de
ce que pouvait être le déconfinement
donc le retard français
l'incapacité d'edouard philippe pas
donner le sentiment qu'ils maîtrisent la
situation et qu'il sait où il va alors
que tous les autres savent où ils vont
ça c'est quelque chose qui pose problème
et qui donne le sentiment qu en réalité
on agit sous le coup de la panique et
qu'on laisse pas faire la délibération
démocratique dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
le vote tout à l'heure et consultatif
mais edouard philippe aurait aussi pu
très bien décidé qu'il n'y ait pas de
débat du tout et donc pas de vote
demain il a rendez vous avec les élus et
les préfets pour leur présenter son plan
de déconfinement au niveau de la commune
de la communication politique
quel message est envoyé justement aux
élus selon aujourd'hui je pense que il y
a une position très ambiguë là aussi du
gouvernement c'est que d'une part le
gouvernement fait mine de discuter avec
les élus locaux et s'appuie pas mal sur
eux pour réaliser des commandes de
masques énormément de collectivités
locales
aujourd'hui font le boulot de l'état
puisque
y avait un milliard et demi de masques
co brandées mais en réalité on en entend
pas vraiment parlé on ne sait pas s'ils
seront disponibles le 11 mai est donc
face aux carences ou défaillance de
l'état les collectivités font le boulot
mais on voit bien que ça gêne le pouvoir
exécutif et particulièrement son
d'administration qui détestent délégués
qui détestent déconcentrer on voit bien
que les administrations de l'état sont
en train de multiplier les attitudes
tatillonne les attitudes de retardement
de toutes les opérations qui leur
échappe et donc de ce point de vue
j'imagine que là aussi le premier
ministre va en entendre parler demain
des difficultés que l'administration que
la bureaucratie française pose sur le
terrain puisque de partout remontent des
informations selon lesquelles cette
espèce de cascades incompréhensible de
bureaux de la rs de ddd direction
sociale sur sur le terrain cette cascade
est une empêcheuse de tourner en rond et
compliquent singulièrement le travail de
protection des populations auxquelles
l'état devrait se coller mais qui
réalisé aujourd'hui par les
collectivités locales et par les
entreprises faut se soulever
quand même ce point c'est qu'aujourd'hui
la solidarité aujourd'hui l'action
contre le virus
elle est menée par les entreprises par
les collectivités locales et l'état est
un empêcheur de tourner en rond
quel est pour vous et l'enjeu de cette
allocution gouvernementale alors que six
français sur dix ne font pas confiance
au gouvernement pour réussir le
déconfinement selon des derniers
sondages
qu'est ce qu'il joue aussi pour edouard
philippe tout à l'heure je pense que les
deux heures philippe est clairement sur
la sellette
c'est à dire que sa façon de gérer la
crise var quoi qu'il arrive soulever des
questions puisque on a quand même vécu
cet exploit d'avoir un premier ministre
qui alors que la crise des retraites
n'était pas terminée s'est déclaré
candidat à la mairie du havre un fait
campagne pendant que l'épidémie
progressé et atteignez la france et ses
semaines qu'il a passées en campagne
électorale sur le terrain ont été des
semaines où l'action ministérielle
a été gouvernementale au sens large a
été complètement défaillante et nous en
payons le prix aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que le retard dans la commande de
masques on n'aura pas beaucoup de
difficultés je pense à montrer qu'il est
directement liée au fait que le
gouvernement était occupé à faire
campagne aux municipales plutôt qu'à
gérer la crise et donc pour edouard
philippe ya un vrai enjeu de crédibilité
personnelle puisque en réalité depuis
ces élections municipales ratée où il
était candidat et où il n'a pas été élu
il est en permanence en train de courir
après le temps est en permanence en
train d'essayer de rattraper une
situation qui lui a échappé dès le début
et sur ce point je pense qu'il joue très
gros et joue à mon avis son maintien à
matignon et vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer
que emmanuel macron fait selon une règle
jamais pratiqué dans dans la vème
république jusqu'ici une campagne
ouverte auprès des journalistes pour
dénigrer son premier ministre et pour se
désolidariser des positions son
gouvernement
c'est une situation inédite dans
l'histoire de la vème république qu'un
président de la république en situation
de crise se désolidarise par avance
auprès de la presse de l'action de son
gouvernement
merci pour votre regard eric verhaeghe
fondateur du courrier des stratèges
edouard philippe attendu